[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i haven't talked to this guy in a
while
but he's a buddy he's an absolute stud
frank isola
the nets studio i didn't know frank was
the net studio he can't say anything bad
about him now
he's the net studio host for yes network
now
why you got to give me somebody
objective fritz you can't he can't say
i know i love frank too much he's your
guy oh my god he he probably has more
jobs than i do which is hard to do net
studio host on yes
siriusxm mba radio the starting lineup
post
espn around the horn and pti
contributor and at some point frank and
i were on the same show
i have no recollection when that was or
what show it was but i know we were on
frank it's ross tucker how you doing
buddy
ross i'm doing really well i think we
did sn y it was either sny
or maybe a show on nbc and i think back
then it was probably more than 10 years
ago and i think you said
that tom brady will be done after this
year i can't see him
beyond 30. i think that was your call if
i remember correctly
i don't know if i said that uh i do want
to get your thoughts look i wanted john
frank
i can't stand the nets everything about
them
now truth be told like mclovin i'm a
sixers fan so we'll get into that in a
second okay
but i do need to start with the patrick
ewing news because nobody knows
you know james dolan madison square
garden the inner workings of the knicks
everything
better than you what is your just
initial
reaction to the ewing comments yesterday
i'll give you a blank slate well i think
first of all i think patrick was a
little tongue-in-cheek
and i also think that after you win a
game like that and every two
he's walking and every two steps he's
getting asked to show his idea i get how
that could be frustrating
but the security guards are being told
to check everybody and in this world
that we're living in with kovid
i'm sure they want to be worried about
which groups of people are moving into a
different area i get all that i'll tell
you this
years ago they had a rule at madison
square garden where they said
no one unless you have a pass
could you get to certain areas james
dolan who owns the place
rolled up and there was a security guard
there at the booth and would not allow
him to pass
and he got upset but the security guard
again was just following the rules that
he was given
i to me it wasn't that big of a deal i
think patrick was excited that they beat
villanova and he probably thought it was
annoying
that he kept getting stopped ross if you
go to staples center
the security guards there wear red coats
to get
back to the locker room you have to
bypass three levels of security to show
your passion how many times i've
walked into the locker room and the
final security guard will say
we'll look at the past and i'll say to
him how do you think i got this far you
think i'm james bond
i had to pass four different guys just
to get here you know i'm legit at this
point
all right so here's a question frank nba
coaches
right because obviously the players are
the players but nba coaches
where do they have the past they get a
pocket in their pocket right they have a
pass right
yeah and also too everyone's wearing
kind of the same
uh you know now everyone's wearing kind
of the same uniform so
it's not an issue for nba games but a
lot of times the coach will walk off the
court with the security guard
they don't get stopped you know who ends
up getting stopped a lot of times
undersized nba players trying to get
into the player's entrance at games
because the security guard will say you
don't play for the team say a guy like
carson edwards on boston who
is like 5 11. you could see a security
guard saying you don't belong here
patrick ewing i i'm surprised that the
security guards didn't know who
they were but i have sympathy for this
is probably their second job
right to make ends meet and they're told
check everyone's pass
that's what they're doing all right so
was it a smart move by ewing because
we're talking about it and georgetown
hoops so much
and the fact they beat villanova or bad
move because
it's overshadowing the fact that he
probably got his best win as a college
coach
and that that that is a fair point again
i think in the euphoria of the moment
you have a million things going through
your head you just beat
villanova you're going to get prepared
to play either seton hall or st
john's that obviously that result hadn't
been decided yet and you have a million
things on your mind you're walking
through the building where you played
and every two feet you're getting
stopped it's it's the kind of thing that
the average person isn't going to be
upset with
i think patrick again and i've known
patrick for a long time
i thought it was a little
tongue-in-cheek his post-game interview
which obviously became a big story
right now we know how good the nets are
we know how talented they are
has it made a difference among the fans
like is there anybody that you know of
frank personally
that is now a nets fan that wasn't
previously i i think ross i think what's
happened
is i think locally in new york the
knicks are still the team
the nets have become a bigger team
nationally because of
james harden former mvp and then of
course for kevin durant you know harden
they traded for he's already played more
games as a net
than kevin durant's had has played
durant didn't play last year he's only
played 19 games this year
but to your point they're just an
exciting team to watch and doing the
games is fun
especially when durant was out there
because
everyone knows that kevin durant is
great but when you see him all the time
and he's playing you have a greater
appreciation
for just how good he is and the nets i'm
watching the game you know i did the
game last night
and boston is a good team and the game
was competitive and you catch yourself
at some point thinking
the celtics are going to have no chance
to beat the nets if kevin durant comes
back and is healthy
he's no one in the east i don't i don't
think could beat them four to seven
times
and really durant is like that's off the
charts harden is brilliant
and then if kyrie irving who is up and
down if he's going to play
like that engaged on both ends of the
court it makes the nets that much better
all right we're talking with frank isola
he's got a ton of jobs including
being the net studio host on yes you can
check out his show
here on seriously now a homer and a
shill yes
that's the starting lineup so here's the
deal though frank
first of all i don't like super teams
and look
we've had that argument a lot of people
know that a lot of people don't like
super teams
and but especially this one
you know kyrie irving is not a likable
guy
hardin in particular the way it ended in
houston
does not seem like a likable guy even
kevin durant frank i'm kind of like
i don't know you know the burner account
and couldn't beat him in oklahoma city
so it goes out to golden state
are there are they a likable team or is
this one of the most
unlikable teams we've ever seen i'll say
this about james harden and i did not
agree with the way that he handled his
exit
in houston i didn't like that at all and
you had a young coach and stephen silas
waited a long time
to get that job fellow ivy leaguer like
yourself
and i didn't like that he showed up for
camp out of shape he showed up late
hardened did so to me that was
unprofessional but since he's gotten to
brooklyn
the one thing about him and this has
been true throughout his career the guy
loves to play basketball so he lives the
life of a single guy
so he enjoys all the trappings of being
a rich single guy but when it comes to
playing
he loves to play basketball he's been
incredibly unselfish
he looks to get other guys involved and
kevin durant is the same way kevin
durant
very rarely makes takes a bad shot he's
unselfish he defends
kyrie irving i could see it because
kyrie's going to say things and i'm
going to make you roll your eyes last
night after the game he said i'm always
about playing
on the big stage well hang on a second
last year the nets went down to orlando
you didn't go
so there was a big stage list or last
year in the summer you decided not to go
down there
i get it maybe the league needs a team
to be the villains and maybe that could
be the brooklyn nets
but i'll say this in terms of the way
that they play especially harden and
durant
they're likable on the court with the
way that they play all right
do my sixers who by the way are
homegrown
embiid simmons homegrown do they have
any chance
to beat the nets all right so this year
joel embiid
has done a couple of things he got
himself in better shape he took care of
his fitness i don't think he's just
eating two hamburgers and a milkshake
every night i think he's worried more
about his diet the big thing will be
can he make it through a season and
playing
most of the games if he does he's gonna
have a great chance to be mvp he's
averaging 30
and 15 which is remarkable and right now
he's he's had five games of 40
points 10 rebounds five of them the rest
of the nba combined has had four
that's how good he's played i think they
could do it i'm a bit
i love ben simmons i don't care that ben
simmons doesn't shoot three pointers the
guy can defend
he's big he's athletic he gets to the
basket doc rivers has done a good job
and tobias harris has been that
borderline
all-star this year ross remember if the
nets play
brooklyn the match-up problems obviously
for both teams
the nets have been unable to stop joel
embiid
that will be a big issue if those two
teams meet in the playoffs uh
i certainly hope so i'm even getting
folks on
chat row like brian guido say has there
ever been a larger group of unlikable
players
on one team or what so shout out
chatrow fair unfair frank
well i understand it because kevin
durant left the small market oklahoma
city thunder
and he went to the warriors who were
already an established team that were
coming off a 72 win season
and this is what i don't get from kevin
durant you wanted to go to
golden state and it worked you were a
two-time finals mvp you would have won a
third title had you not blown out your
achilles
and you left a great situation you left
steph curry
and you're kind of rolling the dice here
in brooklyn now things are kind of set
up for them and if he's healthy
like i said they could make a run but
i think kevin durant if you listen to
him in these post-game interviews he's
been incredibly humble
he has a box score in front of him and
when you ask him a question about the
game
he knows why the team won why they lost
he's just very much engaged and he knows
i'll say this too ross
he knows it if this doesn't work out he
knows it's going to be on him
so for me he's been fully invested in
this team all right you mentioned
embiid and the mvp i'm curious about
lebron because for so long
people were saying lebron mvp lebron mvp
it almost feels like frank from afar
that lebron's playing every game
because he wants to win the mvp and i
like it i don't like these guys that set
out games i like that he's playing
but is he chasing the wrong thing i mean
is he chasing the mvp
at the expense of what might be best for
the lakers long term
well you you're definitely on to
something because if you want to be mvp
you have to go for it and i think that's
going to be the thing with embiid you
have to play
in the games this year especially at 72
and lebron's only missed one
and i think lebron he obviously cares
about his legacy to me he is setting
an unbelievable pace and i think in a
year and you were just talking about tom
brady before
the reason why these guys can play at
this level at this age
is because number one they keep their
bodies in tip-top shape
but they still want to win and they love
competition and i give lebron a lot of
credit he's accomplished more than any
active player right now
in the nba and he still wants to win mvp
and he wants to win one more
championship and that's all that it's
about for him
and it's somewhat refreshing to see and
as you know these guys now tom brady
lebron james
they play the game at a different level
mentally they're just so much smarter
than the rest of the players so why walk
away at a time when
let's face it you kind of have things
figured out but i think it'll be
interesting to see over the next 20
games if lebron wants to be the mvp
ross he'll keep playing if there comes a
point when he says you know what
i'm not going to be i'm not going to be
in tip top shape of the playoffs i'm
going to back off
i think lebron will decide whether or
not he's going to wii mvp this season
check him out on sirius xm nba radio the
starting lineup he's on around the horn
he's on pti
and he is the studio host for the most
unlikable team
in nba history the brooklyn nets thank
you frank
go go penn beat princeton take care oh